-(applause & cheering continue)
-Yes.
Thank you very much!
Thank you!
-Thank you.
-AUDIENCE: Larry! Larry!
-Thank you very much!
-Larry! Larry! Larry!
-Thank you. I appreciate it.
-(chanting continues)
Thank you.
Welcome to The Nightly Show.
-Larry! Larry! Larry! Larry!
Larry! -Thank you very much.
-Please. You're too kind. -MAN:
We love you, Larry! -(cheering)
-I love you, too! I love you,
too. -MAN: We love you, Larry.
I love all you guys!
(laughter)
I am Larry Wilmore.
Um, so, how was your day?
(laughter)
Um...
Mine? Yours was okay?
Well, as many of you
probably heard,
this is our final week
of The Nightly Show. Um...
-(booing)
-I know. Yeah.
Four shows left, and I just want
to thank Comedy Central
first of all,
for this rare opportunity,
and it really is
a rare opportunity...
-doing this thing.
-(applause and cheering)
Thank you so much.
And also,
the staff of this show--
we have an amazing staff,
you guys--
for giving it their all
this past 20 months.
Um, I want to thank, um...
um, all of them here.
And especially,
I want to thank all of our fans.
Let me just say, you guys
have been unbelievable.
We have the best fans in late
night, I'm saying it right now.
-Okay? Right now.
-(cheers and applause)
It's the passion.
Um, it really is true.
People come up, and they never
say, "Hey, nice show."
They always say, "Thank you!"
You know,
it's such a cool thing.
And hearing from you guys
has really been incredible.
Even you, @wilmore_blows666.
(laughter)
I mean, you brought such
a unique voice to the dialogue.
-I appreciate that. Uh...
-(laughter)
Now, when we started the show,
we wanted to have a conversation
on some very tough subjects,
and we've had a lot of fun
doing just that.
I mean, really,
our show was at its best
when the news was at its worst.
And, uh, I'm just so proud
that we were able
to take on real issues,
and, I don't know, hopefully,
say something powerful
while making people laugh and
on some very, very dark days.
Um, my only regret is
that we won't be around
to cover this truly insane
election season.
Although, on the plus side,
on the plus side, I must say,
our show going off the air
has to only mean one thing--
racism is solved.
-(laughter)
-We did it.
-(applause and cheering)
In fact, in fact, in fact,
I think we have a photo
from Ferguson
that was taken earlier today.
(laughter)
Yeah! You're welcome, America.
You're welcome.
But black and white aren't the
only issues out there right now.
Orange seems to be the biggest
problem facing America.
WOMAN:
Yes! Yes!
So let's check in and see what's
happening with the Unblackening.
♪ ♪
(screeching)
(yelling)
(screeching and yelling)
(screeching)
That thing's gonna haunt me
for a long time.
-(laughter)
-It is.
Okay, now, last week,
I made a few jokes
at the expense of Trump's
spokes-goblin Katrina Pierson.
(laughter)
Um, I don't want
to give the impression
I was picking on her just
because she's working for Trump.
I would never do that.
-Goblin lives matter, you guys.
-(laughter)
Okay? They matter.
Ugh!
But then she has to go
and say this.
Remember, we weren't even
in Afghanistan by this time.
Barack Obama went
into Afghanistan,
creating another problem.
-No, no, no, no!
-(laughter)
No, Obama did not go
into Afghanistan!
Now you're just being stupid
for stupid's sake!
-WOMAN: Yeah, there you go!
-Okay?
But I don't understand.
What is wrong with you people?
Perhaps you're not familiar
with all the disasters
from the Bush Administration.
There was a terrorist attack.
We got into two wars.
Vice president shot his friend,
for Christ's sakes.
There was a horrible hurricane,
which, thanks to you,
is no longer the first thing
that comes up when you Google
the words "Katrina"
and "Total (bleeping) show."
(laughter)
-Okay.
-(applause)
-But...
-(whooping)
but... but--
sorry--
maybe you were going fast
and you didn't mean to say that.
Let me give you
the benefit of the doubt.
That was Obama's war, yes.
Mmm...
But look at the confident way
she spews that bull (bleep).
"It was Obama's war, yes."
(laughter)
Now, earlier today she admitted
she got this wrong,
after the entire world told her
she was wrong.
But here's what
really gets me, guys.
She's the spokesperson for a man
seeking the highest office
in the land.
All she had to do was be alive
for the last 16 years...
right, to have known
she was wrong.
And keep in mind, as a goblin,
she may have been alive
for centuries.
(laughter)
All right? I'm just saying.
-(applause, whooping)
-This is possible.
Also, here's the other thing.
And these Trump surrogates
not only spew these lies,
like, with confidence,
sometimes the bull (bleep)
coming out of their mouths
surprises even them.
So to be clear, Mr. Trump
has no financial relationships
with any Russian oligarchs?
If that's what he said,
I... that's what I said...
that's obviously what the...
our position is.
-(laughter)
-Oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
The bull (bleep) is coming
out of his mouth so fast,
you almost want
to hold his head back, right?
-(laughter)
-(coughs)
Go ahead, man, get it out.
Take your time.
(choking)
(groans) But someone
who doesn't seem to mind
the taste of bull (bleep)
in their mouth is the...
is the bovine dung
connoisseur himself.
President Obama.
He is the founder of ISIS.
He's the founder of ISIS. Okay?
-(cheering)
-He's the founder.
He founded ISIS.
And... I would say the cofounder
would be
crooked Hillary Clinton.
Mm, mm, mm.
Please make up
your own joke there.
(laughter)
But Trump soon followed
that bat (bleep) crazy statement
by doing something
very presidential--
sending
a bat (bleep) crazy tweet.
All right?
(audience gasps, groans)
(laughter)
Well, but that's not sarcasm.
Sarcasm is when you tell
your friend with the ugly shirt,
"Hey, nice shirt."
(laughter)
Not sure why you would do that
to your friend
who's just trying
to get back on the dating scene
after his divorce, but...
Regardless,
sarcasm is a pretty lame excuse.
But at least Trump kind of
admitted he was wrong, right?
Obviously, I'm being sarcastic.
Then... then...
But not that sarcastic,
to be honest with you.
(laughter)
"To be honest"?
You're never honest with us!
The end of your sentence
stated the complete opposite
of the beginning
of your sentence.
Do you have any idea
how confused
the middle of your sentence is?
(laughter)
(groans)
I got to Keep It 100
about this election.
Donald Trump
has stopped being funny,
he's stopped being outrageous,
he's stopped being
politically incorrect--
he's just downright dangerous.
AUDIENCE MEMBERS:
Yeah! Yeah!
(whooping, applause)
Let me tell you.
And the worst...
and the worst of it is,
he's just a liar, okay?
And I don't want to hear...
(mocking):
"Hillary Clinton's a liar, too."
Okay? That is
a false equivalency.
Let me tell you something.
Hillary Clinton is a very smart
and capable politician
who many people don't trust
because she spends too much time
lawyering her words
so she doesn't lose votes,
instead of telling us what
she actually (bleep) thinks.
All right?
Donald Trump is a
psychopathic narcissist who...
-(cheers and applause)
-MAN: Go, Larry.
...not only has the hands of an
infant, he has the mind of one.
Okay?
(cheers and applause)
I'm just saying.
I'm just
saying.
And I apologize to all infants.
(laughter)
Okay?
So, stop comparing the two.
Donald Trump is an existential
threat to America.
And if you love America,
like me,
you have to hope
that Hillary Clinton wins
every single electoral vote
this November.
-(applause, cheering)
-Let me just say.
Let me make this clear.
(applause)
It's not so much that
"I'm with her."
It's that I'm with her.
We'll be right back.
(cheers and applause)